hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Horror Thriller
film called Gerald's Game spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
Jesse and Gerald are a married couple
from New Orleans who are going through a
rough patch Jesse is a kind middle-aged
woman while her husband is much older
and selfish they are currently headed to
an isolated delike house in the
countryside for a private weekend
getaway since the couple hasn't made
love in months Gerald wants to make sure
he performs really well hence
unbeknownst to his wife he has packed
two handcuffs along with a pack of
Viagra in his bag Gerald is certain he's
going to get Randy baby throughout their
Journey they encounter several bad Omens
they come across a starving stray dog
feeding on roadkill while the radio
reports a break-in into a cemetery
nearby however the couple brushed the
signs aside and finally arrive at the
beautiful Lake House Jesse goes in to
explore and sees the fridge is already
stocked up for them she then brings out
some meat to feed the starving dog they
saw earlier meanwhile Gerald is in the
bathroom taking a Viagra pill dudes not
wasting any time he stares at himself in
the mirror for a long time unsure if he
can can please his wife today she is a
rocket Gerald you probably don't stand a
chance but outside Jesse is feeding the
dog she appears to be an animal lover
and is really enjoying its company but
just then Gerald calls her making the
dog run away in fear he tells her the
meat was too expensive to be given to a
dog but they laugh it off and head
inside for a fun time Jesse tries to
close the door behind her but Gerald
can't wait any longer to have coitus so
they leave it open Jesse changes into a
new night dress and removes its tag
placing it on a shelf above the bed when
Gerald arrives in his underwear with the
handcuffs Jesse is a bit taken aback but
decides to go along following this he
restrains both her hands on the bedposts
he then takes another pill of Viagra
with some water leaving the glass on the
same shelf above the bed once everything
is set up Gerald tries to enact his
wildest fantasy which would be making
love while she screams loudly for help
hot Gerald you psycho however Jesse who
has become very uncomfortable at this
point refuses to comply she tells him to
stop and to uncuff her but he continues
to enact his sick fantasy angry Jesse
yells at him and forces him to stop this
causes the two to get into a heated
argument and Gerald accuses her of not
even trying to rekindle their romance my
boner's gone Super Saiyan too babe come
on Jesse tells him that these coitus
games are not going to save their
marriage and again asks him to uncuff
her however Gerald refuses to do so he
still wants to have coitus but when he
gets closer to her Jesse bites his face
repelling him dejected Gerald breaks
into tears and starts playing the victim
he believes that their relationship has
fallen due to his incapability to make
love as he continues with his BS
suddenly he feels uneasy and holds his
chest it turns out he is having a heart
attack Jesse can only watch in confusion
as he stops breathing and collapses on
top of her handcuffed self At first she
believes it is a part of a sick game but
when all of her attempts to communicate
with him fail she realizes that
something is wrong in denial she tries
to wake him with her feet but only ends
up making him fall and hit his head on
the floor Gerald is bleeding profusely
terrified Jesse screams for help but in
vain as there's no other Soul For Miles
several hours passed by and attracted by
the smell of Gerald's blood the Stray
Dog enters the room Jesse tries to scare
it away but the defiant dog bites a
chunk out of her husband's arm and sits
down to eat it as a despondent Jesse
breaks into tears Gerald suddenly gets
up and starts talking Jesse is beyond
relieved and asks him to uncuff her
quickly however he looks at his wound
and blames her for feeding the dog
earlier as he speaks Jesse notices that
the dead body is still laying down she
freezes in shock and realizes that the
man talking to her is just her
hallucination Gerald berates her for
wasting precious minutes calling for
help when there's no one nearby he also
calls her a coward for running away from
reality and creating alternate truths
and manifesting ghosts fed up Jesse
squeezes her hand out of one of the
handcuffs and finally frees herself but
when she turns around to to confront
Gerald it is revealed that Jesse is
still handcuffed to the bedposts the
sudden death of her husband and being
stuck with his corpse has started
getting to her head in the next scene
the two hallucinations start interacting
with each other fake Gerald mentions
that her hand won't fit through the cuff
but fake Jesse believes that she can she
also encourages the real Jesse to give
it a try as time is running out for her
in a matter of a few hours she may die
due to dehydration it is getting dark
outside and the dog hasn't stopped
eating Gerald's flesh Jesse has now
become extremely tired and weak she
takes a moment to collect herself and
tries to reach her phone on the side
table but without success just then she
notices the glass of water that Gerald
had left on the Shelf earlier Jessie
tilts the Shelf board and slides the
glass towards her right hand she manages
to grab it but is not able to bring it
all the way to her mouth with no options
left she discusses the matter with her
imaginary friends and they remind her of
the tag she put on the other shelf the
plan works and Jesse is finally able to
drink some water using the tag which she
transforms into a DIY why straw
meanwhile the dog finishes eating a
chunk of Gerald's arm and proceeds to
fetch himself another one Jesse again
tries to shoo him away but her imaginary
friend tells her not to waste her energy
on the animal as she can't do anything
about it Jesse then falls asleep and
later wakes up at night to find a tall
deformed obscured figure in front of her
whose arrival scares the dog away the
figure is carrying a bag full of human
bones and trinkets scared Jesse closes
her eyes shut and repeats to herself
you're not real Gerald's hallucination
also appears and tells her that maybe
she is right he speculates that the
figure could be death himself waiting to
take her Gerald then starts talking in
riddles and calls her Mouse which seems
to unsettle her this triggers Jesse to
remember her childhood when her father
Tom used to affectionately refer to her
as Mouse a 12 year old Jesse is on a
vacation with her family at a lake house
she never got along with her mother
Susan and they always remained estranged
on that day Susan took her other
children on a boat while Jesse stayed
with Tom by the Lake once alone with her
Tom suggests that she sit on his lap as
she did when she was younger the girl
innocently obliges but little did she
know that her sick father is about to
take advantage of her behind her back he
starts performing sinful acts this
incident has left a deep scar in Jesse's
mind and she is still not gotten over it
back in the present Jesse wakes up to
intense pain due to her blood
circulation being cut off the fake
Gerald asks her why she kept such a big
secret from him and in reply Jesse says
that she has many Secrets some of which
are too scary to discuss surprisingly
the creepy man from earlier is nowhere
to be seen But the Shady dog is back he
is hungrier than ever and is looking for
more human meat to munch on Jesse closes
her eyes again and starts reliving her
childhood this time she is in her room
after returning from the traumatizing
Lake trip Tom approaches her and says
that he is ashamed of what he did
however he indirectly threatens her to
never talk about it with anyone he
insinuates that it was her fault for
enticing him so if she ever tells Susan
about it she will probably just blame
her this is the main reason why Jesse
hasn't confessed about the incident to
anyone later in the flashback the whole
family sits over for dinner where Tom
tells everyone that he and Jesse had a
load of fun he also mocks the little
girl saying that they will have a
similar outing again hearing this Jesse
becomes so angry that she breaks a glass
in her hand cutting herself back in the
present Jesse wakes up from her dreams
with an idea she glares at the glass
kept on the plank the imaginary Jesse
approves of the plan but warns her that
it will hurt Gerald on the other hand
thinks it is good because the blood will
act as a lubricant he warns her one last
time to which Jesse responds that she
does not have any other options she
gathers courage breaks the glass and
then severs her hand with it once she
starts bleeding she pulls her hand with
all her might this causes her
unimaginable pain but she doesn't give
up finally her hand slips through the
Handcuff but her skin comes off because
of it Jesse almost has a heart attack
seeing her skin hanging off her hand but
with no time to waste she he moves over
to the other side to free herself when
Jesse can't break the bedpost she is
tied to she tries to reach her phone she
does get it but realizes that it is
already dead despite the setback Jesse
doesn't give up she notices the keys to
her handcuffs and somehow manages to
retrieve them at last with the help of
her mouth she finally frees herself
completely all her hard work is finally
paid off after this she immediately
bandages herself to stop the bleeding
she also tries to drink some water but
throws up because of severe dehydration
her body is experiencing Jesse then
proceeds to get her car keys but she
passes out on the floor from blood loss
and fatigue a while later she wakes up
to the dog biting one of her hands after
Chasing it away she grabs her car key
and proceeds to leave when suddenly she
notices the same giant figure from
earlier without thinking much she pulls
out her wedding ring and gives it to him
the figure carefully watches it without
saying a word as he is deeply immersed
in the ornament Jesse gets in her car
and leaves after driving for a while she
again starts hallucinating because of
extreme fatigue At first she sees her
deceased husband waving goodbye at her
she also sees the tall figure in the
back seat of her car Jesse keeps dozing
off because of it and eventually crashes
into a nearby tree fortunately she is
still conscious and alive after she
honks her car's horn for a while some
nearby people come and rescue her six
months after the incident we see Jesse
in her office fully recovered from her
head injury her hand has also been
partially mended after multiple skin
grafts it is revealed that she didn't
tell the authorities what transpired at
the lake house because she wanted to
avoid the painful questions in her
statement Jesse said that she has severe
Amnesia because of which she doesn't
remember anything from that fateful trip
the doctors have confirmed that Gerald's
death was due to a heart attack she has
gotten her insurance money and her life
is back on track things have gone back
to normal for her however every night
before bed she goes back to the time she
was trapped and gets Disturbed with the
same question where did her wedding ring
go did she really hand it to a ghost who
she thought was her death the question
that even and the cops are reporters at
the scene failed to answer with the
insurance money Jesse has started a
foundation to help young people recover
from their traumas one day she sees a
peculiar looking man named Raymond Jew
bear on the front page of the newspaper
it is revealed that he is a notorious
serial killer who murders people and
strips them of their valuable ornaments
he has been accused of other heinous
crimes like graveyard vandalism and
cannibalism and even necrophilia jubair
suffers from a rare disease called
acromegaly which results in the abnormal
growth of various body parts after he
was arrested they searched his house and
found his sisters and father dead the
latter was consumed partially which
indicates that Juber prefers male flesh
reading all of this it finally Dawns on
Jesse that the ghosts she saw at the
lake house was none other than jubair
she was left unharmed due to the fact
that she is a female and also because
she immediately surrendered her valuable
ring to him after Jesse finds all her
answers she decides to visit the
notorious killer in the final scene she
arrives at the court as juber's hearing
is going on a reporter reveals that he
hasn't spoken a single word since he was
arrested however as soon as he sees
Jesse he gets taken aback and says you
are not real turns out even he thought
she was a ghost Jesse also looks him
right in his eye and starts seeing both
her evil father and husband in him then
she confidently tells him you're so much
smaller than I remember the movie ends
as Jesse triumphantly walks out to the
street with the sunlight gleaming down
on her leaving behind one confused ass
giant deformed cannibal ghost man
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching